hello that's right it's me your mom my
friends were telling me all about this
this movie we got to see they say you
gotta dress up and wear pink and black
the movie's name I believe is Barb and
Hammer oh my God the normies have found
barberheimer officially it's over it's
over the meme is dead I can't believe my
mom knows about barberheimer it's not a
movie it's two movies it's a double
feature that you're supposed to see and
it's supposed to be ironic oh my God
such a normie wow I definitely am
not on Twitter as much as you are God
forbid I wanted to go watch movies with
my friends and have a good time but now
I know that I ruined the meme right
maybe I was trying to bond with my child
who typically sucks
and I was trying to be nice oh laugh at
Mom because she doesn't get me I'm just
gonna go sit in the living room and
drink wine and watch Gilmore Girls
because that's what moms do right you
[__] idiot